We're live.
Welcome Iran, this is iCandy Webcast.
I'm Anthony.
>> [COUGH] Coach Audacity.
I'm also Coach Audacity.
So today we're going to be talking
about structure in your code and
planning out basically priming out your
code before you start on a new project.
We have a question submitted
before the webcast started.
How do you tackle a new project, and
basically that's what this
whole webcast will be about so
hopefully it will be able to answer
that question moving forward.
So I guess we can start.
Jonah, what do you do when
you have a new project, and
you're trying to scope
out what you want to do?
>> Yeah, I mean that's exactly
what I want to do, scope it out.
So you don't want to just dive in and
start with a blank screen,
start typing code.
That's It's hard first and then it's
also frustrating because you'll type
a little bit and then you'll
wonder what should I do next?
Whereas it's best to sort of approach
it with a structural concept so
you'll sort of map out what
you want your code to do,
master the inputs, the outputs and then,
sort of think about what it's going to
look like even before you write it.
>> For sure.
>> That's a blessing.
>> It's almost like writing a paper,
writing an essay.
You want to start out with an outline,
some idea, some direction.
And the biggest danger as we'll
see today is that when you
dive into code without an idea
of structure beforehand
you may not get into a big situation
immediately, but you might find that
the code you write becomes difficult
to maintain, difficult to follow.
And we'll see some examples of
some well-structured code and
some-not-so well-structured code.
So really closely tied
to the idea of structure
is this term that gets thrown
around called spaghetti code,
and what it refers to, it is delicious.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But not
only as a code is it delicious.
But I think it kind of refers
to code that's overlapping and
kind of getting tangled.
And the original definition of it,
I have some code on my computer that
I'm going to share with everybody.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So this is some code,
I'll make it a little bit larger.
So you may not recognize
this programming language.
But this is a programming
language called Basic.
And Basic Six in its index.
You may be able to just look at this and
be able to know what it does.
So Jonah, can you look at this and
do you have any idea of
what it might be doing?
>> Yeah sure.
It kind of looks like you're
defining i as the integer zero and
then you're defining it again and
as itself plus one.
So i equals 1 now.
So you print i which is 1 and
then you have it print
out 1^2 = i times itself.
And then if i is created
in 10 then you go to 16 but
it's not so go to the next and we go
to the next line and it says go to 20.
So go back up and
we'll add one to i, print it,
make it squared and then print that and
just keep doing it over and
over until i is greater than ten.
>> But basically.
So this is kind of
a weird way to do this.
You might already be
thinking that there's
a better way of doing this with
what you already know about Python.
>> Yeah, it took me a little
while to get through that.
Like I get it, but it took a while.
>> Right, exactly.
And that's the big problem here.
So this, to show you that it
does do exactly what Jonah does,
there's a little website I
found here called Run Basic and
Run Basic let's you run
code written in Basic.
So let's paste in our Basic code and
when we hit run we'll see it does,
it prints out all
the squares from one to ten.
So you may be looking at this and
you're wondering what the hell
is this GOTO statement here?
>> Yeah.
>> So this used to be a really, really
common thing with programming languages.
And in a way you're still using it when
you write Python, you just don't see it.
So what's going on here you might also
see these numbers on the side, and
basically one thing we can do is we
can assign lines like an identifier
okay, so in this case we're just
calling each line like 10, 20, 30, 40,
sort of like the line
numbers on Sublime here, but
here these have actual
meanings with the computer.
So like you said, we start out i = 0,
we change it to the value 1.
We print out 1^2 = 1 * 1 is 1.
We say if 1 ≥ 10, well it's not, so we
go to the next line that says GOTO 20.
And so
what GOTO 20 says is go to Line 20 and
it comes back up here and
now 1 = 1 + 1, well now its 2,
choose where it equals 2 x 2 = 4,
and we go on.
Then at some point we'll say when
i is 10 we'll say if 10 ≥ 10,
well that is true, then we'll go to 60,
and 60 is this line Program Completed,
okay.
And then this end statement
is just something for
Basic, to terminate the code.
So, what does that almost sound like?
Given I think about that idea
in terms of like Python?
It seems like you could do just pretty
similarly using a like a while,
while statement like a while i is less
than ten and you loop through something.
>> Right, totally
>> Or like a for statement.
Could do that too.
I'm not sure exactly how
that would pan out but
some sort of some sort
of conditional loop.
>> Right, so basically right,
you're saying the key word there.
It's a loop.
>> Yeah.
>> We're essentially just almost
like artificially creating our own
loop by saying go to this line and
then keep going back to that line
>> Yeah.
>> until a certain point.
So in Python and
tons of other programming languages now,
we have really useful things like for
loops and while loops.
So this is a code that does
the exact same thing in Python.
You see it's only three lines now and
this uses a for loop.
So we're just saying for
i in range(1,10) meaning for
all the number between one and
ten, print out i and its square.
And then at the end
print program completed.
>> That sounds pretty familiar, yeah.
>> Yeah, so I built this.
We see we get the same result
we got with Run Basic.
>> Yeah.
So in a way I'm like the lowest
level because basically what
happens when you write
code in the computer,
the computer doesn't actually
know how to read Python.
And that might be something that a lot
of beginner students don't necessarily
realize.
>> Right.
>> But what's happening is this
Python code is being translated into
something that the computer can read.
And the way that's happening is there
is a goto underneath this for loop.
And what that goto is saying is
that at the end of one iteration of
the loop goto the beginning of the loop.
So it's sort of like it's built in.
Now, why is this is one referred
to as poorly structured spaghetti
code versus this one is considered
nice and well structured?
I don't know if you guys have any
ideas about why that might be.
>> I mean, I guess it's just
a matter of being easier reading.
I found that with the Python one I can
read it basically in plain English,
and I can understand it.
Whereas the other one is, it took
me a minute to read through it and
understand it and
follow the lines to the end.
I have to basically run it in my head,
whereas this,
I can just see it and understand it.
>> Right, exactly.
And that's exactly why we're not
using the goto statement anymore.
This is a cleaner syntax.
It's more easy to read.
I don't see the return
to the loop immediately.
It also is quite frankly really
nice that we don't have goto any
more because it's very easy
to abuse that, all right.
Goto gives you a lot of power,
it enables you to send your code to
wherever you want within your program
but it's very easy to misuse that power.
And so basically there's almost
no way to do it now with a modern
programming language, although
there is a joke module called goto
that somebody developed
as an April Fool's joke.
And so this is what it
would look like in Python,
but we won't waste our
time with that right now.
>> Okay.
>> So
you may be wondering if goto is not
a problem anymore in Computer science
because we have for loops and
while loops, I can say that it's
just a whole lot better things.
>> Why have to worry.
>> Right, exactly, why I have to worry.
Why do I have to take
care about structure.
Certain important parts of my code
are structured for me, right.
Is there even such a thing
as spaghetti code anymore.
>> Right.
>> And I guess in the strictest
definition, there isn't.
>> Okay.
>> But spaghetti code now may refer
more probably to just bad structure.
So I have some examples
of some poor structure.
But before we jump into that,
we'll actually talk about
the problem more generally.
So I don't know if you know this, but
Jonah just opened up a store for
this problem.
And he ships items to places
all over the world, and
he has all sorts of different customers.
And since it's a pretty small store,
they don't offer free shipping yet.
But if you purchase the item and
you live in the continental US,
your shipping cost is $5.
If you live abroad, if you live in any
other country your shipping cost is $10.
And the same is true for
people in Alaska and
Hawaii since that's really far away
from the rest of the United States.
So we want to help Jonah write
a code that tells him what
the shipping cost will be for
his customers.
So the way I'm going to start out
doing this is add this drawing here,
this diagram.
And this kind of gives an idea
of what we want to do.
So we want to say if
the country is the US and
there's a big black box, and you'll
see what's under there in a second.
We'll say,
well just to start out we'll say if it's
in the US then the shipping cost is $5.
And if it's not,
then the shipping cost is $10.
That looks easy enough to do, right?
>> Sure.
>> It's simple if statements
practically written right there for us.
So let's add in,
make sure that it's on the continental
US before you set
the shipping cost of $5.
So, Jonah what do you
think we should do to,
what do we do if it's
not continental US?
>> Well it's going to be the same
as if it wasn't in the US, right?
So-
>> Right.
>> Cost would mean the shipping cost
is $10?
>> Right.
So I mean it seems pretty simple, right?
And you might be tempted to say well
we've got shipping cost is $10
up here and well, that just
wants to go to the same place, so let's
just have it point right back there.
>> Yeah, that makes sense.
>> Seems to make sense, this diagram.
I can read this if it makes
a lot of sense to me.
>> Right.
>> What we'll actually find is
that implementing it in this way,
where you have essentially two branches,
this falls here and
this falls up here,
pointing to the same place?
>> Right.
>> That's going to cause
a little bit of a problem.
And we'll exactly what's going on there.
So, here's some code I wrote to do this.
There's actually two examples.
So this is define shipping cost it
takes in a country and the state.
Or just to make things easy,
we're saying that if a country is
anything other than the US,
then its state is none.
So this if statement right
here is a little convoluted.
You kind of, do you have an idea of
maybe what this is trying to say?
>> Yeah, I guess,
if the country's USA and
the state is not Hawaii and not Alaska?
So any state that's not Hawaii or
Alaska then less the cost equals 5?
>> Right, exactly.
So this very long kind of
difficult to read statement
basically says it's the Continental US.
>> Yes.
>> Then we'll set
the cost equal to 5 and
otherwise we'll set
the cost equal to 10.
>> Okay.
>> It seems to make sense, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Took a little effort to bring it back
for sure.
If we run it,I got some test cases
here so I'll see what it is for
California Alaska, and Germany,
and we'll get 5, 10, 10.
So exactly what we expected,
the code works.
>> It's cool.
But maybe we could do a little better,
make it a little easier to read.
>> Sure.
So going back to our diagram, generally
you're going to get into issues if
you have branches pointing
to kind of the same spot.
And that's exactly what we saw here.
And you can think of it in this way,
right.
So we basically have
three different cases.
>> Right.
>> Right,
we have the case where
it's the continental US.
We have the case where it's in the US,
but it's Alaska.
And we have the case where
it's any other country.
But we only have two end results.
So these don't exactly match up,
that makes the code harder to read.
>> Interesting.
>> So a better way to do
this might actually be,
we'll straighten up the branch here.
Move our, I'll stay on with it.
And we'll make a third box and
put it here.
So you can see the sort of how
parallel the diagram looks now, right.
The diagram itself is
a little easier to read.
It's easier to digest for people who
maybe aren't familiar with the problem.
They can look at this and
follow the diagram.
And you'll see that they'll be
able to follow the code better.
But it is, again, important to think
about how you're structuring things.
So there's actually another bad example
of doing exactly this that I have here.
Well it's not exactly a bad example,
it's better than the last one but
we could do even better than this.
So this one we're saying, so
if the country is the US.
And then we check if the state
is not Hawaii and not Alaska.
The cost is five.
Right.
>> Otherwise the cost is ten.
So what you think is kind of confusing
about this one on first looking at it?
>> I guess I just don't
really know where the else.
Well, I guess I know
where else comes in.
This gets a little bit
complex near like line 19,
like if stay is not Hawaii and
not Alaska and
it's by within the else's like
if it is Hawaii or Alaska?
>> Right.
>> So I guess it's just
a lot of counter positive or
something, very strange
conditional statements.
I mean, I get it because you
explained everything to me.
But on first glance, on first glance
it is a little bit harder, yeah and
probably the hardest thing about
is that you have these like,
this if statement,
within an if statement.
>> Yeah, not only that but
both it statements contain L
clauses that are identical right?
But also you have first of all two
else clauses that are identical right.
But serving different purposes,
and they're also incredibly vague.
Right.
>> Right.
>> You know,
if you could spend some time with this
code you could figure it out and,
granted this is a very small case,
so it might only take you a minute,
two minutes to read and
digest if [CROSSTALK].
You can think of this on
a grander scale then.
>> Yeah, if we had like
a huge shipping network, and
had to calculate like postage taxes.
>> Exactly, it would be terrible.
[INAUDIBLE].
So this is also well it
satisfies our nice new diagram.
It's not the best and if I run it,
we see it works again like you
said as your company grows
as your store grows.
You're starting to you know maybe
decrease shipping costs and maybe
they're different in different countries
this can get out of hand pretty quickly.
>> Right.
>> So there's a better way.
And basically,
this is what I came up with.
There's probably a lot
of different approaches.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But looking at this, do you think you
can kind of explain to the students what
you think is going on here?
>> Yeah, I mean,
it looks pretty straightforward.
You go through a bunch
of these if statements.
So, if the country is not USA,
then it's going to 10, and then check if
it's Hawaii or Alaska, because if
the states are Hawaii or Alaska,
then it's going to be 10, and otherwise
>> It will be five.
So basically you're kind of narrowing
them down from like the largest down to
like the smallest.
>> Right exactly and
that's that's the way that
it seems almost counter
intuitive right so
I think a lot of people when they
first think about this problem.
They want to make this first if
statement, if equal to USA right?
But the most you kind of
want to start most generally,
like build down from there, so
like most general shipping costs applies
to those who don't live in the U.S.
Right that's like the biggest
group of cases right.
So, essentially right.
You're like breaking down
the cases into smaller and
smaller bits as you go along.
And you can see in
the structure of the code,
it looks actually quite similar
to our diagram here, right?
So you have like very
parallel statements here.
You don't have if statements
nested inside each other.
You don't have these confusing,
vague else statements.
You just have this one at the end,
here, which,
maybe there's something we can do
to make this a little more clear.
Maybe we can just put in a comment,
or maybe
we can write it a little differently but
this is a much better structure.
We can run it and
see does the exact same thing as
the last two examples did too.
Yeah.
There's one other type of
spaghetti code that also
comes up a lot too.
And this one's been even more common in
recent years than the ones we've been
looking at here and that's as it relates
to object oriented programming and
you know if you've gone through
stageyou've dealt with some OP before.
It can get a little messy if you're
not there if you're not thinking
about what you're doing as you're going
through if you're not planning ahead.
So for this problem I'll
be the subject of this.
>> Okay.
>> And what's going on here is
I have a car and I drive a car.
My car is driven by me.
I want to make certain code that
shows that relationship, right.
So basically I have two classes here.
One for cars and one for drivers.
And in order to initialize a car you
need to know the model of the car,
you need to know who the driver is.
We just initialize like we always do.
Then we add a little function here.
That if you call this function,
then what it will do
is it will return you the name
of the driver of the car.
>> Okay, that makes sense.
>> So in parallel we'll have a class for
the drivers as well.
Drivers all have names and they all
have cars otherwise they're not drivers.
Initialize like normally and then we
have a function called Drives that tells
you what car that driver drives.
And so down here I've got
some Initializing cases, and
my car is a Kia Optima.
>> Okay.
>> So initially,
there is no driver, right?
A car is built, it doesn't have a driver
until someone purchases the car.
>> Okay.
>> So
that's how we're going to initialize it.
Part of that is because if we were to
try to put something in here well there
don't exist any instances of the class
driver yet so we have to just say that.
But we can think of it as like
when a car is manufactured and
it doesn't have a driver yet.
Then we have a variable for me.
I have a name, Anthony.
I just bought the Optima.
So now I am tied.
The car is listed on my class as mine.
And now we'll just update the driver
attribute of the Optima to be me.
And then at the end,
we'll have some print statements
that use the functions we have.
So if this is working as we want it to,
we want to say Anthony drives an Optima.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And the Optima is driven by Anthony.
>> Yeah, so we'll build it and
that's exactly what we get.
So I have another little graph here.
So this is essentially
what is going on here.
>> Right.
>> You have driver drives is dependent
upon car, and car got.
Is driven by, is dependent upon driver.
And in a lot of ways when you look at
this code it seems to make sense, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Cars have drivers,
and drivers have cars.
It seems to make sense that we
build this relationship, right?
>> Right.
Just thought we had a question
real quick to make sure that
we can see the code because it
was in the Google logo before.
Maybe make it a little bit bigger?
>> That works.
>> Maybe I can get out of full screen.
Is that a little bit better?
Sorry about that.
All right, so then only love like
this seems to make waffles and
lot of ways it does.
Generally, you want to avoid this
type of circular dependency and
that's what that's what we
call this circular dependency.
Can you think of any reason
why this might not be a great,
maybe if you decide to
change one of them.
If you want to get a new car you
would have to create a new object
but then you would also
have to change the driver.
Yeah, totally confusing about what would
happen if you wanted to change one of
those objects.
>> Exactly, so there's two things
that people always say about circular
dependencies, and
that is that they're hard to test.
Because in order for
me to test anything about the car,
it's tied very closely to driver,
so I can't test.
These classes independently
of each other.
>> Got you.
>> It's also hard to maintain,
all right?
That kind of goes into what you said.
If I want to change even
something about a car,
it will probably involve
a change driver also.
Now this can get really bad when you're
working on a very large project,
because large projects often involve
multiple different files
containing many different classes.
And if you accidentally build
in a circular dependency there,
then you could be having to do lots of
changes in lots of different places.
>> Okay.
>> And you're just going to make a huge
headache for yourself.
>> So does that mean you can't make
objects that contain other objects?
No, not at all.
In fact, often times it make sense, and
in this case it sort of makes sense.
What you want to do is focus, instead
try to avoid circular dependencies and
focus on one way dependencies.
So I have a little bit of a read
back there, this initial idea,
and in this case, you'll see there's
no is driven by function here.
We just drives function, and
I could do this any way I want.
Well, I'll talk through code first,
and then we can kind of analyze it,
but We'll have an instance,
the class car,
all it takes in now is
the model of the car.
Whereas, the driver still
takes in a name and a car and
it still contains this drives function
that tells you what car the driver got.
>> Right.
>> So now,
you can initialize optima with just
>> The model of that car
which is a lot simpler than the last
time we tried to initialize it.
And now we can initialize me with
my name and the car that I drive.
So when I run that I see
Anthony drives an Optima.
>> Nice.
>> And you may
be wondering why we don't have
the isDrivenBy function anymore.
And that's true we have
lost that capability.
>> Right.
>> But ultimately, this is easier
to maintain, easier to test,
easier to work with.
>> Okay.
>> So that trade off is worthwhile
for us.
>> Got you.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> So
what do you think is kind of better or
even like worse about this code.
Your initial observations.
>> It seems a lot sleeker like car just
has one variable associated with it.
That's the model driver
as you know one method,
and then two variables
associated with it so
in terms of like the object
itself it's a lot simpler.
It's a lot easier to understand.
It also seems like you can you'll
be able to like one driver
will multiple cars.
>> Right.
Which I guess you could
have done before, but
I feel like it would have gotten
pretty complex pretty quickly.
>> Right.
>> It might take some work to give this.
I don't think it has the ability yet
to take multiple cars.
I'm not sure exactly.
But definitely it's easier
at least to give this
code the ability to
take in multiple cars.
You'd have to work this out so car
could be a list which might screw with
the function, but
still relatively small change compared
to what we had to do in the last one.
And you know it's dependency here.
We have driver depending on car in this
case, I could have very easily done it
the other way around and that's the kind
of thing about circular dependencies.
It's usually you have a choice of which
direction you want the dependency to go.
In this case,
I chose this because I felt that
drivers are only drivers with a car.
If you have a driver without a car
then that person [INAUDIBLE].
But a car can exist without a driver.
>> That's true.
>> So that's always possible.
I'm sure there's an argument for
someone, self driving cars.
the other way around, but
cars need to exist with drivers.
But basically, you can build into the
dependency the way that makes the most
sense for your problem, the way
that makes the most sense to you.
>> Yeah.
>> Just try really hard to
avoid those circular dependencies.
And that's where kind of charting out
and thinking about your problem, and
saying, what is it I'm
trying to figure out?
In a way, the question is driven
by drives are the same questions.
It's just reversed,
so let's cut out some
of the necessary verbage and
just simplify it.
So yeah, those are the examples I had.
Do you have any other thoughts on code
structure and the importance of it?
>> Not really.
It seems like Most of it.
If's cool how it's sort of
like a creative aspect to it,
where we have to think about and
not just in terms of like their coding,
the way they work, but
the way they work in real life.
>> Right.
>> And I think that objects are kind of
a cool way of thinking
about things in real life.
It's like When you do decide to
try to like make a database of all
the trees in the world or something.
You want to think about things
in terms of how to organize
in the real world [CROSSTALK]
translates into code.
>> For sure.
That's one of the things that I think
a lot of people including myself really
love about coding is that there's
a huge creativity aspect to it.
And it's almost like
an intersection between an art and
a science, depending on what stage
you're at and what you're doing, right?
In a way the initial things
we were talking about with
goto being the basis of the for
loop, right?
That's sort of the science
of how your for loop works.
But then when we go into why is a for
loop preferred to a goto statement,
that's more art.
effectively they do the same thing, they
might even do the same thing in the same
amount of time, but
we like before loop, we call it.
Often like the word computer
scientist love to use is elegant.
And it's elegant code, it's simple,
it's concise and
that's sort of like one of the.
Beauty parts of it.
It's like trying to
determine that structure and
trying to make it as
elegant as possible.
And one piece of advice that I heard,
somebody wrote this online,
that as I was researching this, is
never adapt a language to your design.
Adapt your design to fit a language.
I think that was pretty good advice.
You know, sometimes you might find, and
this happens a lot when I'm programming,
is that you'll start on some code and
it's structured a certain way and then.
Some point in you're like
this isn't really that good.
Maybe I should have done
things differently.
Screw it I'm already half way
in I'm just going to keep going.
There's a real importance in
becoming a programmer where it's
I make everybody think about things.
Sometimes you might
have great in life and
have it like the code and realize he
said it structured a little differently.
And ultimately is as we've seen as we
have discussed in the last example.
The earlier you catch bad structure and
the earlier you go to correct it,
the easier it will be to maintain,
and the easier it will be to test,
and it'll make your life a lot
easier to go that route.
That's sort of the thing that
planning helps with that.
Another thing that helps with that is
just being stuck in that situation.
And just saying, it's one of those
things that Anthony talked about.
>> A new experience,
struggle through it.
>> Yeah.
>> All right.
>> All right, cool.
Well, thanks for joining us.
Yep.
We hope to see you next time.
>> Yeah, definitely.
>> All right.
>> Have a good day everyone.
>> Bye, guys.
[BLANK_AUDIO]